well it looks like Marvel Studios could
be making some pretty big changes to the
MCU and of course this could be either
really good or if executed improperly
could be bad what's going on everybody
welcome back to the channel I'm your
host Warren Thompson and the changes
that Marvel Studios are making and have
actually currently made already have
fans kind of concerned but don't worry I
think that this is actually a really
really good thing now what is Marvel
Studios going to be changing well one
they're going to be changing the
frequency that they actually release new
projects to the MCU and no I'm not just
talking about the series on Disney plus
what we're talking about today are
specials Marvel Studios has begun
releasing what they call specials in the
MCU and here's the thing sometimes
specials could be extremely important
but sometimes they might not mean
anything at all however all specials
will be Canon to the MCU and this is
something that Marvel Studios is doing a
lot more in the future now what are
special well they can be many different
things and I think they're an excellent
idea but I can understand why fans are
worried and of course we'll talk about
that in this video now specials can be
anything from the I am Groot series that
we got on Disney plus to werewolf by
night which is about to come out in a
few days it can be the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special and it could also
be some type of a short film introducing
a new character to the MCU now all of
these which I mentioned are and will be
Canon to the MCU meaning they take place
inside the MCU storyline and like I said
each project could have a very big
impact on the MCU from very small to a
very large impact but let's be clear
this is a very big deal and specials
will have a serious impact on the MCU as
a whole and if you're thinking that they
don't matter or the stories won't really
connect or be anything big well Marvel
Studios president Kevin feige has
already came out and confirmed that
specials will indeed have a very serious
and big impact on the MCU and once you
see werewolf by night in a couple of
days you'll realize why also here's
another perfect example James Gunn has
already confirmed that the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special is Canon and
is quite important it will contain very
important info that you will need to
know meaning you'll have to watch the
holiday special to know what is
happening in the Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 film James Gunn specifically said
that this is MCU Cannon it takes place
between Thor love and Thunder and the
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. so these
are a big deal and according to a new
report from thecosmiccircus.com Marvel
Studios is considering doing a lot more
specials and once you see this I believe
that you'll think that these specials
are a really good idea in theory of
course again it's all how it's executed
which of course we'll talk about but
let's first talk about how this could
potentially be bad it's pretty obvious
that a lot of MCU fans have been
complaining about the quality of phase
four and to be fair the series on Disney
plus started with phase four and some of
them were really good but some were kind
of just okay now some people can
attribute this to that's just how it is
you're liking some things but not liking
the other things however some people say
that Marvel is kind of putting out too
much content right now focusing more on
quality and not quantity phase 4 has
introduced the Disney Plus shows plus
we're getting three to four movies a
year this is a lot more content plus we
do hear the news about the visual
effects artists being overworked and I
can see that especially with all of the
new content that came in phase four
however I think if Marvel can fix a few
things and make one thing very very
clear this could be a really good thing
more content with specials in a very
different way could very much work I had
the opportunity to watch werewolf by
night last week and I can tell you that
this special really works I thought the
one hour special was fantastic this is a
new way to introduce characters into the
MCU that will go on to affect the larger
MCU and I actually found it quite
refreshing that it wasn't exactly an
origin story and it wasn't a really long
dragged out story either they kind of
just introduced the character and left
they showed us who the character was
they showed us what he was about they
had a really great story which did wrap
up in the special and then they ended it
now they did introduce other characters
like man thing and Elsa Bloodstone and
they're going to go on to have a big
impact on the MCU too however this was
still very much a werewolf by night
story that involved these other great
characters this could open up the MCU to
a much bigger greater side for example
for the MCU werewolf by night is truly
kicking off the supernatural side we
thought it started with Moon Knight and
it kind of did but once you see this
you'll understand and this is what Kevin
vaige had to say about the special he
said we wanted to explore entirely new
characters and entirely new sides of the
MCU with this unusual fun and
frightening spin on the Supernatural and
Kevin feige did this through a special
and it worked so these specials can be a
very great thing and they can be very
important and some not matter really at
all but still connect to the MCU and can
still be very very enjoyable if Marvel
Studios gets one thing right let me
explain what that is the perfect example
is the I am Groot series it was fun and
it was what we expected we knew that it
wasn't going to be a really big show we
knew it wasn't really going to impact
the MCU that much but it was MCU Cannon
and it was fun it was a fun time that's
what we expected is it MCU Cannon yeah
does it really matter to the MCU no not
really well in groot's case kind of but
still not really to the overall MCU does
werewolf By Night matter yes it does it
introduces characters to each other and
shows clear relationships and
implications but at the same time it is
a standalone feature which also opens up
another really great thing that these
specials can be used for Marvel can make
specific movies that they want to make
and not really have to focus on the the
rest of the MCU but still connect in an
interview with comicbook.com director
giachino talked about working with
Marvel and making the film he said
cameos never really came up I mean we
talked a little bit about blade but in
the end it was like you know what if
we're looking at this and I always
describe this as an episode of The
Twilight Zone you know let's keep it
contained this is one night in the life
of Jack and Elsa and let's see what it's
like and I know everyone searches for
connectivity and we want this person in
here and this and I was like no let's
just do this it exists in the same world
as all of these other things it does but
let's not worry about that right now
we'll deal with that maybe someday I
don't know but for right now I wanted to
tell you the story of one night in the
life of these characters and hopefully
something that you could just drop in on
not having seen anything else and just
enjoy it for what it was I personally
really like this idea and I think a lot
of fans will as well this is something
that you don't have to to watch anything
else in the MCU to enjoy I've heard a
lot of people talking about how people
have been skipping Disney Plus shows
because they haven't really been
enjoying them however they're kind of
bummed because they do need to know what
happened to know what's going to happen
in the future of the MCU for all of
these team up films and movies that
connect with each other so this is a
stand-alone film this is a stand-alone
story but at the same time has very very
big implications for the MCU and
introduces new characters that we'll see
down the road this is why I actually
really loved werewolf by night and why I
love the idea of doing specials if
Marvel can level our expectations and
let us know exactly what to expect if
we're going to get a show like I am
Groot that's just going to be silly and
fun they need to let us know which they
did before however when it comes to
She-Hulk my personal opinion is they
marketed it kind of the wrong way it's
not really what they said it was going
to be which is why I think a lot of
people actually aren't really enjoying
it this is why I think that expectations
are a must from Marvel Studio and
marketing needs to be on point for what
they're releasing this has the potential
to really expand the MCU and introduce a
lot of new characters they could use
this to introduce characters that we
really love like Nova we know a Nova
project is coming however it hasn't
really been clarified if that's going to
be a Disney Plus show or a movie or now
it could even be a special now some
people might say well I want a full
movie to introduce a character and some
people might say well I want a full
series to introduce a character but
again if the story is right these
specials can be really great they could
also be used to describe stories that
are kind of taking place outside of the
main MCU storyline again they connect
but do they really matter no but they
could be a lot of fun so overall I think
specials could be a really great thing
to the MCU if done properly and of
course if Marvel sets these expectations
but at the same time I understand how
fans might be pretty skeptical of this
so be sure to let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest new news and for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof